Pixar's Elemental appears to have flamed
out at the box office what factors
exactly LED audiences to throw cold
water on the prospects of this charming
looking animated flick from a once
reliable Studio
typically Pixar and Disney releases are
incredibly heavily promoted even films
like light year which drastically
underperformed at the box office saw
lots of Television ads promotional
tie-in releases and merchandise hitting
the shelves before the movie hit
theaters but Elemental didn't seem to
have that same promotional enthusiasm
behind it television ads for it were
rare Disney related fan websites noted
that the company just didn't put much
promotional muscle behind Elemental
leaving it to flounder much like
Disney's Winter release Strange World
the result appears to be the worst
performing Pixar release since A Bug's
Life in 1998 with a paltry 44.5 million
dollars worldwide opening weekend this
was not supposed to happen worse when
Pixar did try to get people talking
about the film they caused a mild PR
disaster a tweet featuring Ember one of
the movie's leads and a fire Elemental
parodied the poster art for turning red
the Tweet proclaimed Unleash Your
Wildfire side with this burning red
poster straight from element City sadly
the tweets were release coincided with
widespread Canadian wildfires which sent
hazy smoke into several cities in the
northeastern U.S resulting in Twitter
users accusing the studio of
insensitivity the Tweet was deleted but
it's emblematic of the lack of thought
that went into the promotion of the film
at large it's possible that Pixar's
offering was simply muscled out by other
recently released animated films such as
Spider-Man across the spider-verse or
perhaps Disney chose to allocate its
marketing resources to Indiana Jones and
the dial of Destiny or it already spent
them on The Little Mermaid whatever the
case it's very clear that the movie
didn't get a whole lot of marketing
attention before being released
Pixar fans usually turn to the studio
for the exciting and unusual whether
it's a tale of toys that becomes
sentient when people aren't around a rat
who's sole ambition in life is to become
a Gourmet Chef a family of superheroes
who have to live Incognito thanks to
government restrictions or a robot
surviving in a post-apocalyptic world
who finds purpose in true love this is a
company that knows how to create Unusual
original stories that still reflect real
life Elemental doesn't exactly continue
that tradition though the dull beat by
beat storytelling is what holds the
movie apart from other enchanting Pixar
films unsurprisingly Elemental has
failed to make much of an impression as
an original concept bringing nothing new
to the plate narratively even as it
presents a very nice visual experience
Well we'd also just like to note that
the film's allegory is a well-covered
subject with its water Cloud dirt and
fire people working as stand-ins for
people of different races religions and
gender orientations ember's battle to
break free and see the world beyond the
borders of fire town is a metaphor for
the second generation immigrant
experience and while it's arguably a
message the world probably needs to hear
right now it's also a set of themes that
have been done to death by this point
namely zootopia tackled these ideas with
more Styles seven years earlier
there's nothing this summer box office
loves more than family-friendly movies
but theaters are currently Awash with
other films that kids and parents seem
to be finding much more interesting or
at least more entertaining movie-going
experiences than Elemental Spider-Man
across the spider-verse Disney's own
live-action remake of The Little Mermaid
Transformers rise of the beasts and
Springtime holdovers Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 and the Super Mario
Brothers movie have all proven to be
stiff competition while this might seem
to portend doomed for any project not
based on a previously established
franchise audiences only need to look
back to late 2021 to remember when
Encanto swept its way into the Public's
imagination and took hold of the pop
charts with the song we don't talk about
Bruno there's plenty of room for
something fresh to break through it just
needs some extra oomph that Elemental
seems to be missing
to put it bluntly the cast of Elemental
doesn't have any big name actors to buoy
it up to Greater success the film's best
known performers are Wendy McClendon
Covey who voices Gail and Catherine
O'Hara who plays Brook Ripple comedy
fans certainly know both their names but
they're not necessarily proven box
office draws when you make a film about
elements you are just setting yourself
up for the puns well it's arguable that
movies like Ratatouille and Toy Story
would have been just as successful if
every single member of the cast were
unknown a film like Elemental which
didn't necessarily have an immediate
hook it's possible that added star power
may have driven audiences to theaters in
larger numbers of course big names don't
always mean success Chris Evans headed
up the cast of light year and he wasn't
enough to drag the film out of the box
office basement Disney's decades-long
history of hiring talented character
actors instead of big name celebrities
to play its animated characters has
never damaged the brand before now but
in a world where there are so many
options at the theater a little star
power definitely helps draw dollars
one has to wonder if Disney's decision
to put three Pixar films all of them
intended to be big screen successes
directly on Disney plus had an impact
the kova 19 pandemic of course meant
that theatrical releases weren't
feasible in 2020 and 2021 and the
company also clearly wanted to drive
subscriptions to the streamer there is
some evidence that these decisions may
have changed habits some analysts have
claimed that making so many of Disney's
films direct to streaming has taught
families that they don't need to head to
theaters to see them that said it
doesn't seem to apply in every case The
Little Mermaid was a box office hit with
families eventual Disney plus release or
not so if families are willing to show
up to see some Disney Productions in
movie theaters why was Elemental such a
mess maybe it's just a Pixar thing it's
worth noting that the last Pixar movie
to really score at the box office was
Toy Story 4 in 2019. it's clear that
Pixar is struggling to recapture a fresh
point of view and find new ways to tell
its Stories the studio has definitely
produced original unique work before
Hope hopefully it will be able to climb
back to those auspicious Heights with
time
[Music]